for those who are joining us on the live
stream this is a designer view of some
new blockchain functionality going into
the upcoming version of Wolfram language
and let's see which version should I be
running in I have choiced many Venturi
what's that um eleventh row is fine yes
okay I've got only which build the most
recent build should worried the most
recent yes
you
okay let's try rymus them
should I run the initialization code or
not oh that's the essence you may have
the packet so just from the button
information so yeah seems you have oh
you have 58
yeah can you render that's not that's
not wait a second what is this so what
you need a 61 so can you run the
initialization so there's a link to
record install liner
so now Colonel yes - sure
really okay yep and now you can run
those lines or your notebook
I don't want to run initialization again
right no yes we're working fine uh and
the air node Bluetooth cash that that's
a that's a mind hash is that correct
that's why it has yes that's for a big
game how do i plaudit how does the
theorem what is the what is the mining
process there why why does it not does
it have distinguished hashes or not
I'm sure hashes I think they that done
that years prefer steak instead of proof
work I don't know who knows that here
do we have everybody who's supposed to
be here here which we don't I'm sorry
yeoreum is moving toward proof of stake
but it's not there yet yes how come it's
hash it's not there's not a bunch of
zeros in it like the Bitcoin one I think
the number of zeroes is to do with the
difficulty I don't know why yeah I
understand that's but that's the
standard way it's mined in Bitcoin okay
alright anyway so minimum fee why isn't
that why doesn't that have units Oh
should have smoke yes and we already
asked for said dashes to be included as
young who's doing that
working with Alan and Eric why Stein
good luck doing you bring them here know
if you can just get a status on it
because we're kind of urgent right now
that there's an active threat on it so
it's we actually already have satoshis
and Bitcoin and need to hurt ethers you
can say something like quantity ten
eaters that already exists why can't I
say quantity ten Satoshi Satoshi Xia why
is it satoshis because it's all units
are plural okay so why isn't the spirits
earnest Satoshi's yeah that there will
be the case that's I'm not sure that the
plural of Satoshi is satoshis somebody
should check that let's hurry Satoshi is
from the guys name right there yes yes
yes yes but I'm just asking somebody
will check that I'm sure when they put
this in but but so you can go ahead and
change this to returning quantity
objects right I just checked it it's
correct okay all right so right change
that to return in quantity object okay
yeah sure okay the output order should
be type named core version okay looks
good and now this is transaction count
from documentation why was that I can't
remember their transaction count was the
number of elements in the transaction
list yes that's correct
okay so also changed we we were using
log splitter API for the Bitcoin
blockchain but I change it to block
cipher D so when we use for your theorem
because the other one yeah okay okay but
but but so this particular line by the
way do I have to update documentation
immediately to - is it is it um if I if
I updated a few hours ago do I have the
latest versions I rushed it this I just
touch it during the morning okay okay
fine um
okay right so it's not working so did
somebody deal with that no it did work
I'm wrong it worked
I made you okay Isis good twice okay so
now the properties are of bît-yakin a
theorem are more consistent okay and
still now
okay so this is
yes that's one description there was
missing the short for my description
okay so hold on a second okay additional
properties um let's see
blockchain whose name for the block
okay next block hash hash of the next
block what is that well why are we I
don't understand that how do we know the
hash for the next block
that hasn't been mined yet I don't
understand that oh you're looking at
blockchain block data so it can be an
already mined block I mean you're not
necessarily advice last like um why do
we have that uh it's the voltage in API
provides it okay but but hold on
what's difficulty what why are we even
specifying difficulty for our own
blockchain because there's no we're not
we're not requiring anything to happen
to mind a block on our own blockchain
yeah we can take it out to be discuss
that right the difficulty is very low is
that right we don't really know we are
we are only once make right now it's not
meaningful I think we should future eyes
everything in this block here I don't
think any of that makes any sense and
end the section we are there above it
then okay okay because I don't think we
want to define the difficulty okay what
I'm saying but then do you also want to
not return them I mean right now and you
know should we should we allow it even
you know should we allow it just as a
thing that's there that we don't really
well okay so this would be blockchain I
mean blockchain data difficulty and
that's on our blockchain right that
would be a global property of our
blockchain yes right yes
that
that's what oh hi since your music 11:3
and that you wanted to message right
okay so but but I mean if I do this
difficulty is there a notion of
difficulty for there is 4/4 beat going
but the API will use doesn't provide it
okay okay
that's the that's the current difficulty
isn't difficulty something that remains
constant for a long period of time yes
yeah eventually changes to maintain
average have in the case of bît-yakin if
Irish of 10 minutes per right button
minor block huh we I mean isn't there
some other way to get that data is can't
we can't we request that data from
somewhere else it's a it's basically a
constant yes I mean I mean yeah you know
how close it is it's a constant as in
constant four years or constant four
days yes I think so you you're asking
about just hard coding it and that value
even though it may change tomorrow no
I'm not suggesting hard coding it I'm
suggesting it getting it from somewhere
but you know it should not be too
difficult to find a place to get it from
now I mean even so one thing we can do
is to not mess with the back lid itself
we can just have a club object
requesting that friendly for an API and
that would be fine fine okay so if
that's the case then we would have
but this difficulty is not I see
difficulty when mining this block so
that would have to be something that we
would have to find even going back
historically for when a particular block
was mined if we want the difficulty to
be at this level of blockchain block
data correct right yes
okay so we'd have to go back and do that
research so we're not going to get that
done immediately but it's something to
think about for the future um there are
so many ice that provide that so yeah
it's just a matter of checking
you
uhh
you
okay so this thing here this the block
encoded difficulty target which I don't
think is a very good description but
isn't that also global to the blockchain
I think I think it's a little bit like a
good luck
sorry what was that
that is for your luncheon data you have
to use blotching blog data to get the
property
you
I don't understand up
is that so that is use as part of a
formula to also compute the difficulty I
think their bits isn't bits like 11 or
something or whatever that term to go
what I'm saying
no okay I thought that the the
difficulty had to do with the number of
zeros you were trying to have in the
target hash it's related to that yes
okay so how does it manage to be 486
million oh this is specifically bits yes
so that it should be something like 11 I
think
you
and I think we should feature eyes this
because I don't think we know what we're
talking about yet okay okay
by the way is there a guide page for all
this stuff
yes it's called blog cheat
I mean it's future I stand it needs to
be reviewed because it's kind of I won't
say it completely in okay all right so
that was the first thing we were looking
at was properties on the blockchain
what is this poaching block data byte
count are you wearing those results
without the Union okay okay so this was
my list of things that you updated okay
so now what else are we looking at here
so we're looking at
you
this is a summary of all functions and
their blockchain basis okay looks nice
okay let's take a look down here that
that's the basis for writing the
examples I think in okay so these prices
should be in eighths right and these
should have units right I believe so yes
you
what is that
I'm a net that really right
the name I see that's the name okay fine
that's a common use of the bot of the
Bitcoin main blockchain there's a pest
net as well that we don't use but it
exists right I see but you can round up
function again because I think you have
the old version and yeah so the new API
returns I said just like the with
aetherium like eth main little soldier
sell BTC it's more consistent yes that
looks nice
okay let's take a look at the etherium
case blocks since fork nine blocks
before fork why did it fork is that
happening all the time and can we see
that fork how do we see the fork I'm not
sure had this here for but at least
during my day since yeah I see that
number change in the law
okay does somebody know how that works
John dan anybody else how does that work
I mean I I didn't think the the
blockchain had been forked I thought
that was kind of the point I mean the
theorem one got forked when the doubt is
asked to happen but I don't think it
didn't know of other Forks it's nine the
number of sort of unconfirmed
transactions that are still being
processed since it's sort of like a oh
very well be like like the four million
one is like all the ones that are an in
agreement and F in check cross checks by
right I don't think this name is blocks
before fork doesn't make sense to me I'd
like to know what that is - somebody
know what that is here it's the ID at
the time of the fork I understand but
what is the fork what fork is it
something to do with confirmation of
things or what it's not like a a fork
like what happened with the DAO disaster
it's some other kind of right right
okay so what is it I think when then was
saying make sense well but let's make
sure it's right
because I don't think that name is right
if it's some okay so this difficulty
thing okay but it will make a note take
a look at it and I think that's
resolvable and then yeah also yes and a
different name if it's okay well let's
let's keep going here just to look
through these okay Carla D ever yep
thank you okay so bite count is the size
of this block is that right yes and it's
only got it's got a limited number of
transactions and it is what this seems
to say just like two transactions is
that typical well that's an old block
you know I have to say as we you know
use this more and we are you know
jumping around on these block chains all
the time you know from blockchain to
blockchain I kind of think we might want
to support another syntax here where
it's something like you know um
something like this maybe this isn't
right but something like
in theory Amero that as an alternative
to specifying the blockchain base maybe
that's not right the right thing to do
but it seems like we're jumping
blockchains all the time I mean or you
know cuz right now we've got a dollar
blockchain base I think in practice
it'll be less because people will pick
one in and set the base yeah in these
exact list yeah we're just doing it a
lot because we're and if you use it as a
first argument it becomes kinda like
more like a service connects that syntax
you know like I mean that there'll be
you know all right we'll have like 10
different cryptocurrencies at some point
I mean we can also support
yes service connections to different
right to the different API yes do we
have those right now and all the other
they're documented or not
no the implementations were doing just
for this partly because eventually we'll
have our own notes so it's just
temporary okay alright so here
oh my weekend
okay what an earth is bits doing here
what is that
that's a 1u future ice okay
oh but this is much shorter now
yeah the gun from the okay fine great
you may have to reevaluate everything
then second oh yeah right that was
because we shortened it cuz we didn't
understand what somebody's were so
confirmations what would we still okay
we got bits here but we just future eyes
that right yes
to know what it is before we kill it
forever
you
you
you
I think you run the output oh I did run
the output yes you're absolutely correct
when earth is this
Patricia yeah I want to look at these
transactions here
okay
inputs
this mean
you
what does this mean
so I believe is the like the Orion
address and the destination address and
the code the etherium virtual machine is
running what is value
what I'm sure
okay so listen look we're gonna go
through this one more time and the next
time we go through this somebody has got
to understand what every single one of
these things is okay sure
you
you have to run that again also now the
yeah the block is smaller yes block hush
wait a second but we've also still
the inputs and outputs here yeah that's
for a Bitcoin which we don't understand
yet
okay that's a big
action
so at its creamy square were spent
underscore be by that that's not our
kind of naming convention
sure sure it's gonna be fixed
type yep
hey to pub key hash where are those
names coming from four are from the APA
we should figure out what they are and
those addresses what are those addresses
are they like
wallet
vacations of some kind or what the world
takes care of the algorithm it it's not
the wallet itself but what is that
address and the one receiving the
transaction no no I understand but if I
go and I say you know do we have a way
of querying what any information about
that address regarding this version okay
but in principle I could ask to look for
I could do some kind of blockchain
search where I ask for all transactions
associated with that address correct yes
I think that should be possible we one
of these API see it seems like that
would be potentially of interest to me
because that will be analogous to the
search capabilities we have elsewhere
and we have sort of a syntax for how to
do that
but there's only the address right I
mean it's other than that these private
search foot sure but you could search
for things like you know all
transactions above this amount in during
this period and so on okay so what is
all this stuff here again we this is
what we were supposed to go over is you
know
we need to know what every single one of
these is so that we can figure out you
know how are we designing this
right I mean I have no idea what a lot
of these things are I can guess I don't
know for sure um
okay but let's do in progress I mean
it's just fair enough okay what else
should we make sure to look at because
I'm gonna have to go fairly soon here
all right the guy Beach okay okay and
more into the future we should take a
look at the exchanges like financial
data of definitely you know USD / you
know BTC those are things I think we
have something but it's not updated
every day but that's probably what
that's no good
I mean we gotta have some I thought we
had something was updated in real time I
thought we'd had that for like years I
don't think so did that I think so does
that work but I don't think we have I
mean do we have aetherium stuff also I
mean we should have currency convert I
didn't try currency converter I tried
financial data off USD / BTC well no I
don't know financial data is a somewhat
okay don't put it on your chat if you're
not no no no I I believe you I'm just
I'm saying I don't think that's the
financial data thing is some kind of
market yeah I don't know what that is
that's that Brazil Nerissa yes correct
okay and if I want to see historical
data on that if I look at currency
convert does this work if I just do
I should be able to say dated okay that
looks like I'm this mistaken because the
financial later works as well okay all
right well problem soft - okay that is a
problem which should be fixed that dated
is not being supported correctly in
currency converts that is an Allen
problem I think okay so to go [ __ ] take
a quick look at the guide page no I
don't think I've ever written kind of
thing yet okay get information about a
particular block about a complete about
get current information about the
blockchain it says current information
always there's no there's no way to do
some kind of dated query for previous
information right no okay
um this is a great base was written six
months ago so it just hasn't been
updated much since then okay okay
it blows is for interacting both private
blockchain well
okay we want to say here and maybe we
don't need to write this right now that
we can has built-in capabilities for
retrieving information about block
chains and transactions um-hmm well okay
I'm not sure I can write this right now
okay do you want to Eric here I need to
do in terms of the chat please oh I am
hold on one second do you want me to
take a stab at it first if you want I
mean I think we should make this is not
difficult to write let's take a look
down here okay okay current information
about a blockchain get information about
a particular block based on its hash or
something well hi sure height
information about a transaction what's
blockchain hash do we even have that no
we don't have that no okay I'm gonna
have to leave in a couple of moments
here um okay I mean I can help it is
took on a general blockchain information
[Music]
and then we want to say here
you
you
my chain base and dollar blockchain base
actually maybe we should dumb
you
you
okay
[Music]
insert data I mean this is only gonna
work for our block trade yes
you
you
we might want to add the plural
blockchain to the spelling dictionary
okay
I use a different word when we can use
the same word get data
both incapable
is for interacting with blockchains it
can retrieve
detailed information from Bitcoin
theorem blockchains from the Bitcoin
you
you
and also
I'm not sure that's very good but it's a
start I probably should go over this one
last time um
okay anything else we should look at
right now I think the most important
thing is I really want to understand
what all of these different names and
things mean okay and did you update this
because this doesn't look like it's has
been updated
yeah we worked on that later okay all
right great well it's really nice this
is looking really nice and well done on
getting aetherium in um okay and I can
also discuss right now you think that's
it okay see y'all soon then okay thank
you